hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February [ __ ] 17 what's going
on how are you ah Jesus Oh busy bill
what's he gonna do now [ __ ] sitting
in a car while my lovely daughter is in
one of her classes with a mother so this
is the only time a day I have is a day
off I don't if you guys get the holiday
is this MLK Day is this Presidents Day
is this Flags Day huh
it's some day and I got today off but
you know what you know when you're a
parent for all you non parents out there
if I could just talk down to you for a
second about how difficult my life is
because I made the conscious choice to
become a parent and now I'm gonna
lecture you as if you made the decision
that I became a parent is there anything
worse than listen to these [ __ ]
[ __ ] parents talking ah you know how
hard it is and how deep it is and how
much they love their kids you know not
saying I don't do it but Jesus Christ I
should be allowed everybody else
shouldn't be in my world I'm allowed to
[ __ ] nobody else's you know isn't that
how it works well is it well this is
gonna suck because it's gonna eventually
get [ __ ] hotter and hotter in this
goddamn car as I'm running my mouth so
that's just you know what it's just
something I'm gonna have to deal with
this is just one of the sacrifices you
make when you become a parent so ah [ __ ]
somebody's calling me at Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ one hour that's religious
that means I'm calling you back in an
hour
and if you don't know what that means
you don't call me enough and we're not
really friends you know I just feel like
as a parent if I'm doing if I'm doing a
podcast people should respect how tired
I am you know I do you know what kills
me is [ __ ] Leonardo DiCaprio already
made a movie called Blood Diamond okay
so people saw how hard people are really
working
yet they still [ __ ] about being parents
like what they're like they're out there
with one [ __ ] arm digging shiny rocks
out of a [ __ ] hill you're not all
right you listening to kid music over
and over and over again it drives you a
little crazy it's about it but you still
you got all your limbs right we've been
listening to this French CD you know on
like a loop my kid knows all the [ __ ]
words though Tom what is it isn't saebom
offseason soda gazing dig easier
something like that's not what the
disguises I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is yeah you listen to him a lot of times
and that's hard you know I know getting
dug blood diamonds out of the [ __ ]
side of a hill inside a hill with one
arm and not making any money right
oh maybe stealing it somehow and then
stall I can't I can't say that cuz then
I'll ruin a movie um alright let's plow
ahead shall we I know I did some things
this week I just can't remember what
I've been working so much I did flap us
last night out in Burbank I'm gonna be
there again tonight
running my hour because I've been really
busy and I have a bunch of shows up in
Vancouver and you know what I got to
tell you something I have a tremendous
respect for all the stuck-up [ __ ] up
there in Vancouver who want to act like
they're in some sort of European city
when they're really not
alright they're really in some cow town
that they put some skyscrapers in and
then you know because they're near the
water they feel like their culture okay
so I don't need them and they're snarky
reviews coming at me so you know I did
some I [ __ ] rift this thing about
beautiful women the other night and it
killed then last night I tried to do it
and it felt felt flatter than my [ __ ]
ass on a Sunday whatever that means so
that was a little disappointing but the
other [ __ ] is really working out for me
and I don't know I don't know where my
act is right now I had this whole new
[ __ ] act and now I added a couple
other things and all that [ __ ] that i
thought was part of my new Act
got sent down the [ __ ] River I did
like a little over an hour last night I
feel like I did four subjects you know
because I've always been a long winded
hack but anyway I'm gonna run my power
again tonight and flappers not sure if
there's any tickets left but it's gonna
be a good time and I'll be ready to go
come Thursday Friday I think Saturday I
know what the deal is you want to see
what's killing me is the my Boston
Bruins who picked up four points this
weekend they beat somebody and I watched
the game and I have such a dad brain I
can't remember who the [ __ ] they played
I watched the middle of the second
period until the end of the game and I
watched the Flyers play Tampa Bay that
was a fun game and then what else did I
and then the Bruins beat the Rangers
that's right well they're also playing
Vancouver they got a little west coast
road trip coming up and the day after my
gig
they're gonna be they're gonna be in
Vancouver now the old me before I became
a parent I would have stayed but you
know as a parent you have to make
sacrifices I've already been to a home
game of the Vancouver Vancouver Canucks
I've already seen Bruins games I've seen
Bruins games on the road you know you
just do the math or do I want to go home
and ride bikes with my kid you know it's
a no-brainer
then she'll take a nap and I'll watch
the [ __ ] game perfect perfect that's
what I'm talking about hey is uh is
what's his face got his 40th goal yet
huh 88 there and the Bruins why can't I
remember anything this morning who's on
our first line Marshawn pasture not
David pasta no Jesus Christ
has he got his 40th yet he's stuck on 39
for a couple of dead games you know can
I be an out-of-shape [ __ ] sports
writer now and ask him what's going on
does he think he's gonna stop at 39 he
marches coming up you think he'll make
50 if you make 50 what's the bonus in
your contract
I think players should be able to opt
out of [ __ ] postgame interviews you
know I think Ally got to lighten up on
selling the game all right the game is
sold we're all there half the people in
the crowd are dressing like they're
playing at the [ __ ] game right
for God's sakes what more do these guys
have to do asked to stay answer the same
stupid least you ought to be able to
just sarcastically answer the questions
like I saw this one guy dude they were
like you know you got outrebounded of 40
rebounds to Fagin 22 can you explain it
he said well you know basically you know
the ball hit the cylinder and you jump
up and you reach and you grab the ball
and you pull it down and if the other
team does that more times than you then
they get more rebounds it's tremendous
tremendous you're gonna [ __ ] sit
there and ask a stupid question you
should get that sort of a sarcastic
response I feel in my world that's what
I believe yesterday me and Bert
Kreischer I got tickets to the Wildcats
vs. the Renegades the XFL game and I
don't think we could had a better time
you [ __ ] rode over there
pulled in right as the game was starting
you know they played in that little a
stadium at the San Diego Chargers I
think are finally moving out of the one
down there in Carson Los Angeles
whatever the [ __ ] it is and uh oh man we
had a great time we had a great [ __ ]
time I didn't get any souvenirs somebody
took my [ __ ] Wildcats towel by the
time I got to my seat oh god he comes -
here comes the cops he comes the boys in
blue pulling by my car I got a
microphone and head headset on is this
illegal
am ia reporter let's see if he sees me
does he see me now he doesn't he was
looking the other way
alright so we went to that [ __ ] game
and it was just weird I've never been to
the first game home game of a team of a
brand new league their first home game
ever it's [ __ ] hilarious because you
don't know any of the players names
there's no history there's no rivalry so
I just started cheering like I was a
die-hard fan but like you know since the
beginning of the game so I just kept
saying [ __ ] like you know when they were
losing like they didn't score a
touchdown for the first three quarters I
was like Jay it's quite
how long do we got many quarters do we
have to put up with this
let me gh it's been 90 minutes and then
some sick of it this is what I'm paying
for and I was surprised by how many
people around me didn't get what I was
doing but you know and then that can I
kept making fun of you guys if you go to
annex FL game you got to make fun of
that ref with the Red Hat because I
still don't know what it's for
so you say hey what's your red ad for
right ad Red Hat is the Mike Wright ads
to Mike it was actually somebody
recognized me at the game he goes hey
bar shut up I don't know what happens
when I go to a sporting event even stone
sober I just become a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
had a great time too when it came down
to crunch time I was calling out place
you know 64 towards power trap see if
anybody would get it but we had a
[ __ ] great time and great [ __ ]
fans the fans were [ __ ] hilarious a
lot of people boozed up they just feel
fun they just got into it oh and then
like the Wildcats were down right and
they were trying to get us to do this
year you make an X with your clothes let
Klaus out you know there was gonna be a
little hip hoppy about it - yo shout out
to all the wild cats out there it clots
out yo you would constant song
everybody's gonna act like they're
[ __ ] they did a little jail time and
didn't get raped you know you know that
vibe everybody's gonna act like they're
[ __ ] tough it was a little bit of that
the players thing if I could have some
suggestions with the league the players
are amped up they're not professionals
when it comes to speaking in a
microphone they're football players so
they're gonna start yelling when they do
pull the microphone away from their
mouths like I just did they don't seem
to do that they just
blow out your [ __ ] eardrums but uh
our seats were like in the Sun you know
and I'm a fierce Qian Jin Jovi so I
spent the first half you know with my
hoodie over my head and I was like all
right let's go stand up in the shade and
then that's when it became a good time
we started meeting all these people Bert
Kreischer was getting recognized right
and left people asking me to take a
picture of the two of them was [ __ ]
great
Bert can't hide that's what I noticed
about Bert Bert Ken Bert is very
recognizable you know the second he
steps out they just I don't know what it
is but we found Bert crushes people they
are at the XFL games and we just stood
up there and we were just you know we
would share and just acting like idiots
they got the wave going which I thought
was hilarious they should do the wave I
would never do the wave in an NFL game
but an XFL game I love it
okay this isn't the NFL why don't we do
all of this you don't [ __ ] piss me
off is there allowed to make two forward
passes as long as you is you're still
behind the line of scrimmage you know I
don't know why and they were going then
this is just gonna open up the offensive
playbook and you know what I saw
yesterday I saw two coaches trying to
get a ride in the NFL that's what I saw
all right and Bert Kreischer said it he
said you know that what they should be
doing she should just be [ __ ]
throwing bombs that's what the AFL did
they opened the game up who is ever
designed in the history of football who
has ever designed a two forward pass
play nobody because it's not legal
unless it was legal back in the crazy
like Johnson days but nobody remembers
it you could be a [ __ ] pine you could
be the Bill Belichick of the XFL design
a [ __ ] play that looks like a sweep I
mean it's really just a halfback option
thing that I don't like is that you have
to do it you have to do it behind the
line of scrimmage you know what be
[ __ ] it would just open the game up
is if you could throw a forward pass
wherever the [ __ ] you were so then you
hit a guy right he catches the ball and
he's running
now the other guy covering the other guy
wants to peel off and help with the
[ __ ] tackle but he can't because his
guy will then become open and then the
other guys running can does does he have
the intestinal fortitude as the
defensive back close enough to throw
back against his body across the field
that also opens up for an interception
he's not a quarterback I guess if he did
that would we just become too crazy I
don't know but I just feel like a bunch
of people over in Europe um you're
actually describing [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] rules football I'm sure I am I'm
sure you have a bunch of [ __ ] to say to
me because I live in a better country
than yours yeah we're bankrupt okay it
was built on slavery and genocide but
when you take that off of the table what
do you have you have the land of the
home of the free and the brave
we got planes you want planes we got
planes you want mountains we got that
[ __ ] you want lakes you want rivers what
do you want you want a couple of black
bears brown bears whatever [ __ ] you want
we got all that [ __ ] we have all of that
[ __ ] and we make the best music we make
the best blue jeans you make the best
[ __ ] movies you know it's true
and by we when I talk about the arts
specifically specifically music I'm
taking credit as a white person as if
black people didn't help us tremendously
you know we kick your ass the Olympics
shout-out to black people Summer
Olympics it is yeah what are you gonna
do our Olympics are kind of segregated
huh I'm an athlete you're white all
right put on some mittens you're gonna
be at the Winter Olympics get the [ __ ]
out of here whitey Jerry
I didn't think that my life would come
to this that I'd be sitting alone in a
car that's rapidly heating up screaming
into a [ __ ] microphone with a
windsock on it even though I don't have
the windows down I really didn't think
that there was gonna come to this but
evidently it did but you know what I
just had one of those [ __ ] weeks I
had a great [ __ ] week and then
someone just had to be a [ __ ]
you know now part of it is on me I gotta
drink some water here people so I don't
pass out from [ __ ] dehydration you
know each year over 29 podcasters die
recording their podcast inside of a
rented Prius with the windows up okay
now if they're just doing a half-hour
episode they have a 37% more chance of
survival okay I'm not saying that
they're not gonna walk away with some
sort of brain damage I just want you two
people to know the risks that I'm taking
for your own free entertainment as a
parent I'll tell you there's a lot of
drinks out there but is there anything
better then ice cold tap water you know
that is the greatest [ __ ] drink ever
[ __ ] all these goddamn deliveries okay I
will take my water out of the tap I will
boil it I will watch a third of it go
away into the air I will watch a rain
cloud develop in my [ __ ] kitchen okay
when it reaches the saturation point I
will then stick the pot underneath it
and then I will drink that pure
rainwater out of the pot that still has
them the pollution it just making the
whole thing a waste of time
more of a science experiment all right
this is what pissed me off okay
I doubt a tweet a harmless little tweet
I think I know what you think the second
you said I say a harmless tweet you like
oh god what white chick who decided to
stop shaving a clam got upset it's not
it's not one of those they don't shave
my privates now you know that I'm smart
and I'm making a good point
um I don't care what's going on down
there all up there anyways I was gonna
get a breakfast too
something like was going to get a
breakfast burrito went with the oatmeal
and fruit anyway crucial old man
decision hashtag no nap before noon and
the amount of [ __ ] that I got actually
use more protein in a breakfast burrito
if you knew anything about nutrition
blah blah blah and all this type of [ __ ]
let me [ __ ] tell you [ __ ] Internet
[ __ ] something alright nobody knows
what the [ __ ] they're eating at this
point okay you can debate what group
it's in blah blah blah Blee and all of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you have no
[ __ ] idea what was in that chicken
unless you raised it okay if you didn't
raise the chicken if you weren't rubbing
that pig's belly before you [ __ ]
slaughter that thing I don't want to
hear a [ __ ] word out of you you don't
know what they sprayed on your broccoli
I don't give a [ __ ] what farmers market
you go I don't give a [ __ ] if it says
organic I don't give a [ __ ] you don't
know what you're eating either so shut
the [ __ ] up I do know this if I eat a
breakfast burrito
it's like [ __ ] Ken Patera put me in a
sleeper hold
alright I'm sorry who used to do that it
wasn't Ken Patera
depending come on Ken Patera but he
lifts you over the head it was at Tony
Atlas wait a second who used to put me
asleep Adrian Adonis adorable adorable
Adrian right he used to put you in the
sleepy he'd go good night Irene and then
[ __ ] put you in a sleeper hold that's
right but I feed a bowl of oatmeal I
feel like I have energy this guy's was
sitting that time so sick of people
being afraid of carbohydrates
carbohydrates don't make you fat what
makes you fat is [ __ ] take it in more
calories than you burn your dumb [ __ ]
you know eggs are not all bad then I
don't everything's highly [ __ ] use it
right if you just did heroin once a
month I'm sure it's fine
once a month as long as you didn't get a
hot shot I think you'd be okay isn't
that right sir I gotta let some air in
here oh Jesus oh my god that feels
wonderful Hugh Majan if I get Fung you
know you [ __ ] hilarious is normally
this part of the city I'd be worried
about getting mugged but for some reason
because I'm recording a podcast and I
feel like you people who are listening
but aren't actually here I feel safer oh
my god tremendous tremendous tremendous
thank you all right excuse me sir you
know I was watching this [ __ ] it so
anyways getting back to that [ __ ] all
right I don't want to hear a [ __ ]
word of anybody about what the hell I
eat if I eat something and it makes me
feel good in the long run I'm not
talking about eating a cupcake and be
like oh my god my toes are twinkling and
before I have to take a nap okay if I
eat something and it makes me feel good
all right I don't need to be food shamed
I don't need carbohydrate shamed who the
[ __ ] is a problem with oatmeal and fruit
[ __ ] sitting there because eggs have
protein but wait yeah you know a lot of
things have protein and then you throw a
bunch of [ __ ] on top of it and then you
having a [ __ ] heart attack
it wasn't an egg it was an egg you know
in a breakfast burrito you find me one
goddamn [ __ ] personal trainer out
there that would tell you a breakfast
burrito I'm not talking a healthy one
I'm not talking a gluten-free one I'm
talking one that came off of a [ __ ]
food truck there was a whole stack of
them all right if I ate that [ __ ]
thing all right I would have [ __ ]
nosedived and we all know what a cute
little nose I have and the last thing
you guys want to see is for me to do a
faceplant you already have to look at my
giant bald [ __ ] white head all right
thank God I have a nose cute as a button
right right in the center of it it
balances out my head you know I look
like that clock but you don't want to
give us see a clock you can't quite make
a decision no I know I've been talking
about I'll tell you one thing I gotta
get me on the podcast all right because
for some reason okay
my wife she sees a little artsy fartsy
okay she's a little tipsy wipsy she's a
little cutie-patootie she wants to
invest in art I do not I don't know
anything about art other than the less
it looks like what they say it is if the
person who painted it dies then all of a
sudden it's worth money so she showed me
a picture of something right and I'm
like all right I go what the [ __ ] is
that she goes you like this painting and
I'm like no just cuz you don't like it
okay now when your wife does that mean
that means you're gonna buy it
when she asks you your opinion and you
say do you like this when you say no I
don't when they go why or you don't like
it that means that's basically you ever
see a boa constrictor
[ __ ] grab somebody she just grabbed
you and now she's wrapping around and
every time you answer is like that
[ __ ] animal exhaling and that just
squeezes a little bit tighter until you
pass out except at least in those videos
the animal dies but it's the husband you
continue living and you have to look at
that thing hanging on your wall or
sitting in your living room or [ __ ]
driving into your driveway that you
didn't [ __ ] want so she's like what
do you think of that I was like I don't
know what the hell that is and she's
like oh it's it's a no it's a parakeet
or something
then I go that doesn't look like a
parakeet she's like see that's what I
like about it it's up open for
interpretation and I'm like well see
that's what I don't like about it
because it doesn't look like a parakeet
alright just because everybody figured
out how to draw a parakeet in order to
be different you have to draw a parakeet
that doesn't look like a parakeet now
there's no rules right and now I got to
buy this scribble Dibble horseshit and I
saw this whole [ __ ] documentary or
maybe somebody told me about in a bar
I can't remember what we're saying what
[ __ ] the [ __ ] scene is that it's
basically there's like four or five
families that have vet invested in art
and they move the market just like the
stock might I don't get involved in that
[ __ ] but here's the thing
what do I want to do do I want to not
you know I'm gonna stick to my guns this
time I IRA know she's gonna get it she's
gonna get that [ __ ] goddamn parakeet
sitting there and then I have to sit
there and you know look at the signature
and then look this person up and like
once a month check the obituaries to see
if this person died and I'm never going
to get my [ __ ] money back you know
what I mean I mean if you go out there
and you buy yourself a one-level ranch
you still got people know what the [ __ ]
it is and even if you lose money and get
something for it right I don't know my
wife is more educated into that [ __ ]
than I am so I'm just gonna like I'm
gonna I don't know what I'm gonna do
whatever I'm gonna do I shouldn't say it
on this podcaster she'll probably
[ __ ] hear it and then she'll know my
strategy so if you're listening
sweetheart III don't understand I I can
I [ __ ] hate museums okay there I said
it
I don't [ __ ] like him I go in there
nothing looks like anything okay I don't
like that I have to go into a painting
and I have to figure out what the [ __ ]
this guy was trying to say okay it's
like talking to a crazy person on a bus
I don't know what you're saying and I'm
not gonna sit here and try and figure it
out
I'm not a psychologist okay I don't know
what that is I'm sure it's amazing I'm
sure it means something to you I'm sorry
that whatever happened to you happened
to you that made you do that to a piece
of [ __ ] paper
okay you know what tree died and you
just [ __ ] vomited colors all over it
you realize that right
at least it could be something that we
knew well what is it
yeah I'm just gonna I don't know what I
have to do here I know I'll just do it
you [ __ ] handle it maybe I'll do that
maybe I'll just let her do it and then
when we take a bath on all of these
[ __ ] paintings any time she gives me
[ __ ] I'm not even gonna look up for my
food I'm just gonna point to it on the
wall and just be like is that guy dead
yet cuz I can't get my money out of that
[ __ ] thing oh god we got a three year
old
let's get an expensive piece of art and
put it on the [ __ ] wall I'm being a
jerk I think it's cool that she likes
that type of stuff I'm [ __ ] kidding
so you know she wants a couple of artsy
fartsy things on the wall that's fine
you know then I'm just gonna be like
alright well then here's the deal I have
to be able to buy an artsy fartsy
painting of John Bonham okay of
something that I like a beautiful woman
[ __ ] smoking a cigar and Cuba I don't
something that I'm into you know anyway
I actually well I found the [ __ ]
video oh my god
I got to post this [ __ ] video I've
been trying to find this video forever
with this guy from Cigar Aficionado
tells the story about being down in
Mexico and this guy gave him a real
[ __ ] Cuban right and he just [ __ ]
took out the butane lighter and lit it
up and that the the the dude almost had
a heart attack like what are you doing
then showed him the whole story about
how he had three matches
just look up cigar fiction out of three
matches and he showed the patients
that's the greatest thing about it even
if it is any if it's just whatever it is
but it's just like to do that and the
focus and the concentration
he doesn't he doesn't he doesn't cut it
and draw air in you know to help light
it
he doesn't clip it he just [ __ ] sits
there with the match and slowly turns to
cigar and he has those long matches and
he likes it takes three of them and then
he finally Clips it and then he draws in
and none of the chemicals off of the
match are drawn in and affect the taste
of the tobacco it's just it's awesome
and if you're a cigar smoking or cigar
smoker you'll appreciate it unless you
were [ __ ] anyway by the way March 10th
everybody all freckles is going to be
playing drums with Dean del Rey on his
40th anniversary of Bon Scott Bon Scott
died February something 1980 so it's
been 40 years and Dean Dell raised the
man and he's going to do a tribute to to
Bon Scott and he's got all of these
people coming out I don't know if I'm
allowed to announce the lineup but I did
I did because I don't know with
everybody torn but he's got some major
major major major musicians coming down
there and then I'm gonna be sitting in
for a song or two embarrassing myself
and that's gonna be on March 10th at and
the Avalon right across from Capitol
Records on vine in Hollywood March 10th
it's a Tuesday all right so all right
let's read some of the advertising here
where the [ __ ] is my damn phone I just
had it I don't have internet out here
this whole [ __ ] thing is just falling
apart for Christ's sake for Christ's
sake bill what are you gonna get your
[ __ ] together and get a studio all right
we got some live reeds here rake on
everybody I don't know this one rake on
look around you it's a wire it's a
wireless world man and everyone needs a
great pair of wireless earbuds but
before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
the wireless earbuds from Ray Khan you
already know ray Khan earbuds start at
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market I
did not know that now I know that I like
this and they
just as amazing as other top audio
brands you know I'm liking everything
about this and rate cons latest model e
25 is their best one yet with six hours
of play time seed you could be a
triathlete through the whole goddamn
triathlon probably with one pair I don't
know how long a triathlon takes I'm just
saying six hours is great
so I across the country seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit Rea cons wireless
earbuds are so comfortable perfect for
on-the-go listening and for taking phone
calls unlike some of your other wireless
options
Raik on earbuds are both stylish and
discreet with no dangling wires or stems
yeah those straws that hang out of
people's mouths I mean sorry out of
their ears I hate those things you've
heard me talk about how the company was
co-founded by Ray J no you did not it's
the first time I'm reading it and
celebrities like please pick Snoop Dog
cardi B Melissa Etheridge brandy jr.
Smith
why wouldn't I say all of them was a
huge names well they're using them and
they're obsessed with Rey Khan's pick up
a pair and see what the hype is all
about now
now's the time to get the latest and
greatest from Ray Khan get 15% off your
order
and buy recon comm / / that's bu y ra y
co n comm / berg for 15% off recon
wireless earbuds buy rake on comm / /
well that makes a lot of sense
you know anything that's apple's gonna
cost ten times more than it should right
all right policy genius oh my god
they're so smart the year 2020 shows up
in a lot of science fiction a lot of
people predicted that by now we'd be
teleporting to work or living on Mars
can you imagine if the teleportation
actually existed and you could actually
be questioned for a murder in Seattle
and you were like well I was at home in
Los Angeles watching television yeah and
that's a teleport machine right over
there I swear to God I didn't use it a
lot of people predicted that by now we'd
be teleporting to work
on Mars and a lot of those predictions
were wrong wrong the truth is we'll
always get the future wrong which is why
we need to get life insurance over there
barstool sports they get it right when
they're gambling Dan Katz David Portnoy
I think they're talking about technology
which is why we need to get life
insurance right
that's where policy genius can help
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find your best price you could say
1500 bucks or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies that's great once you apply the
policy Tina's team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape if Paul's a
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home and auto insurance or
disability insurance so basically
whatever insurance you're looking for
these guys can help you out so if your
science-fiction dreams for 2020 still
haven't become science fact don't get
discouraged get life insurance it takes
just a few minutes to find your best
price and apply at policy genius.com
policy genius we always get the future
wrong man but we get life insurance
right
and lastly no not lastly Jesus Christ
hymns 66 percent of men start losing
their hair by 35 Hey spoiler alert once
you've noticed thinning hair it can be
too late now Jesus is that hairline
slowly starting to move backwards any
bald spots yet let me check the best way
the best way to prevent more hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have some it's time to grab the
New Year by the follicles here's to a
year of personal growth I swear to god
one of these times I'm gonna do this
just as a joke I am coming out with a
[ __ ] bright orange like the Sun
lion's mane I'm gonna grow my beard out
just come back looking like I'm in the
[ __ ] Eagles a [ __ ] ginger Don
Henley and why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
turn to medicine and science for hims
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss
skincare sexual wellness for men this is
what I love about these people they're
like well you're gonna get your hair
back so then the Broads are gonna start
knocking on your door so you got to
clear up your skin and make sure your
dicks gonna be standing at attention to
support the troops it's time to write a
new chapter one in which you have heya
thanks to science baldness can be
optional hims his helping guys be the
best version of themselves with licensed
physicians and fda-approved products to
help treat hair loss no snake oil pills
or gas station counter supplements hims
was created by a guy who knows some
men's health conversations are easier
online than in person for hims connects
with you to real doctors online which
could save you hours completely
confidential indiscreet answer a few
questions a doctor will review and if
they can determine it's right for you
can prescribe your medication to treat
your hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door this holiday season Jesus
here's some old copy let it grow let it
let it grow let it grow let it grow with
hymns I was gonna try to cover for you
guys and say you were talking about st.
Patty's Day coming up dive into 2020
fair first right now my listeners can't
get started with their first month for
free go to four hymns calm slash burger
this for him calm slash borough recruit
prescriptions require an online
consultation with the physician who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate only valid offer valid only
if prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details and
important safety information remember
that's for hims calm cyber all right now
lastly but not leastly now yeah calm
this here comes the money shot it comes
the [ __ ] headliner of the reads brave
you are living in the surveillance
economy what is that you might ask every
time you download a webpage you are not
just downloading the context text and
images you're also downloading privacy
invading trackers many people many
popular media sites over have over a
hundred trackers on every page so what
you might say your digital profile
includes information about you such as
your search and watch history your
personal beliefs or even your location
everywhere you
Ben and even your current GPS
coordinates start using brave brave
stops data grabbing trackers and creepy
ads from following you across the
webpage the web sorry which allows you
to browse up to six times faster than
the other browsers here's an important
fact about us brave isn't anti ads brave
is anti tracking brave users can choose
to opt in to brave ads a privacy
respecting ad network run by brave with
brave ads you can earn rewards for any
ads you choose to view that's right
out-of-the-box brave will block ads and
trackers but you can choose whether you
want to see ads how often they appear
and get rewarded for your attention if
you click on one how does brave make
money if you choose to opt in to brave
ads brave takes a cut of the advertising
spend whatever you choose to view an ad
that's how brave earns money and keeps
the browser free free it takes less than
60 seconds to switch to brave and port
your bookmarks with one click and start
enjoying a better internet listeners of
the mmm podcast can easily switch to
brave today go to brave comm / / and
download brave today that's brave com /
/ and switch today today today today
today all right let's get into the reads
here
Oh God oh Jesus we're gonna continue on
remember this guy last week he was
talking about he had a hump in his nose
the Humpty nose is the nose that keep on
growing but it maybe you can find some
chick that wants to sit on your face
maybe she'll like that bump you know
anyway sorry no hump surgery boy
listening to the 18 year old ask about
getting rhinoplasty and wanted to China
in chimed in alright so those of you who
weren't listening to the podcast this
guy just summed it up there was an 18
year old kid who was convinced that the
reason why he hadn't been laid yet was
because he had a little bump in his nose
and I advised him not to get a nose job
just to start saying hi to women making
them laugh and someone would be sitting
on his face faster than he could say
rhinoplasty I'm a lady and growing up my
dad always gave me [ __ ] about how big my
nose was granted it wasn't mich
shapin just long he would say I had a
bird beak Jesus Christ why would you say
that to your daughter and referred to me
as a toucan bird I developed a big
complex about it and looked into plastic
surgery inevitably I [ __ ] doubt because
of the pain I'd be in now married my
husband loves my nose and says it's one
of my better features I'm still not
comfortable with it but I feel I have
grown into it more I have no regrets for
not going through with it and you found
love parents kids are gonna be mean
enough at school you don't need to help
bullies out by adding [ __ ] just done why
would you [ __ ] why would you say that
to your cheek kid I don't get it I don't
get it depends on how old you are though
if you like in your 40s then I get why
your dad would say it you know it was
just a different time that's just what
you did
people just made fun of you right now we
know that that [ __ ] people up I can't
imagine ever doing that Jesus Christ why
would you do that to somebody I'm sorry
that happened to you I'm glad you stuck
it out look at you found love and you
found someone who really loves you you
know all right
it's a good feel look at that feel-good
story Joel Olsteen life story oh god
here we go Joel Osteen's dad was a
Southern Baptist pastor in Texas in
started Lakewood Church oldest I always
wanted you know when you're the son of a
pastor does he make you like go out in
the garage and preach to him you know
until you're like crying and he's just
like you ain't going to bed until you
make me get up out of this chair Holy
Spirit this [ __ ] guy just walked by
looking at me like I was a [ __ ]
lunatic and you know what I am [ __ ]
screaming about the Holy Spirit
goddammit headphones and a microphone
all right Joel decide I have to leave
this door open it's hot as [ __ ] in here
sorry enjoy the sounds of traffic joel
decided to go to college but didn't
graduate I like this guy instead he
started the church's television program
it became televising his dad
sermons what we're dealing with here
ladies and gentlemen is one of my
favorite things on the planet a
self-made man he did that for years
until his disease basically the Vince
McMahon of preaching you know Vince
McMahon's dad ran a regional business
Vince took it over and turned it
national turned it into a national thing
anyways he did that for years until his
dad finally convinced him to start
preaching Joel did his first sermon in
1999 shortly after he started his dad
passed away from a heart attack Oh God
Joel took over after that and continued
on the old family business
dude he made it quick he did his first
sermon in 1999 he's had that [ __ ]
he's had that [ __ ] Astrodome whatever
the [ __ ] he bought there in Houston he's
had that thing for ten years Jesus cried
in faster than a hot chicken showbiz
shortly after he started his dedicate
whatever as you mentioned he purchased
the arena where the Rockets used to play
and renovated it that's [ __ ] great I
think you know you look at goddamn
Atlanta Georgia
that [ __ ] Georgia Dome was fine they
just didn't load it and build a brand
new one it's environmental disaster
where the waited winner [ __ ] it all
the trash from the Georgia Dome go right
in the [ __ ] ocean maybe they saved a
couple of beans sold a few seats it's a
[ __ ] joke
now something from Atlanta is gonna try
to defend it you know reportedly these
renovations by the way they're anything
funnier than watching Houston Astro fans
having their backs up about that
cheating scandal I mean they've been
nice to Red Sox fans but if anybody says
the Red Sox cheated on the last one I'll
be like a [ __ ] absolutely they did
[ __ ] em I don't give a [ __ ] good on them
we're not giving the trophy back
I've reportedly Astro fence you just
gotta roll with it I guess we did you
should try it sometimes ones last time
you won one reportedly these renovations
cost over a hundred million dollars how
the [ __ ] did he afford that that you get
a loan and you're a church so you don't
pay taxes you paid off [ __ ]
twice as fast cuz they don't take 50% of
income anyway he does sell out the arena
to over 50,000 people when he's there
that doesn't hold 50 that doesn't hold
50 it's a basketball arena probably with
the basketball court is about 19,000 you
fill in those [ __ ] seats is he have
people sitting behind him he's selling
anywhere from 20 I would say to about
24,000 anyways he does sell out the
arena arena to over 50,000 people
whenever he's there however he doesn't
always stay there all in caps you were
wrong he and his wife are currently on
tour oh man I wanted him so bad like s
you got to keep [ __ ] feeding the flock
yeah but for the most part he's there
right even he's talk show host
occasionally they'll go on tour but I
mean they go to the same studio every
day they don't have to go to [ __ ] LAX
but he probably flies private oh man if
Joel Olsteen if you're listening I want
you to pray for my envy that I have for
you in your show business lifestyle this
is just this man is the greatest and he
kept his hair you know he's just you
know he's in great shape god bless him
he and his wife are currently on tour
they are doing the Toyota arena in
Ontario California get the [ __ ] out of
here in April then they'll be at Yankee
Stadium in May dude I'm blowin I'm gonna
go with Bert Kreischer I'm gonna see if
he's around I'm not gonna heckle I'm not
gonna be a [ __ ] I just want to see it
tickets are about 15 to 25 bucks but
when you figure out how many of those
gullible Jesus freaks he packs in there
the high-pitched voice squinty eyed [ __ ]
is gonna make a killing good for him
well you know what this bald freckled
[ __ ] is gonna go see him I'll go get him
fifteen to twenty five bucks that Joel
Olsteen
Joel Osteen with the power of the Lord
he figured this game out how did he
figure this game out it's the best it's
the it's the best it is the best you
know when he has a very tough job
because all he has is the Bible
you know what I mean I mean I know it's
a lot of pages I know a lot of it
doesn't make sense to the average man
but how many stories can you pull out
and everybody's pulling from the same
[ __ ] you know it's like a stand-up
comedian we got the entire [ __ ]
universe you can pull from this guy just
has the Bible you know what I'd set it
that way on purpose because I'm trying
to give him another subject you know
somebody told me I was talking about me
coming up with with sermons and and and
and they were saying I feel bad for Joel
Osteen because all he has is the Bible
let's just think about that for a second
all I have is the Bible I have the
universe in my hand I better close my
door somebody's gonna [ __ ] whack me
this is gonna be weird all right sorry
god bless Joel Olsteen and God bless
them for making all those people feel
good somebody's got to do it God knows
the [ __ ] bankers don't [ __ ]
Stephen [ __ ] all right la squirrels hey
Bill I was wondering if squirrels in LA
hibernate even though it never reaches
really low temperatures there do they
still bury nuts out of habit let me know
well I'll get right on that sir I'm
gonna start [ __ ] observing the
squirrels I never really noticed that
they took time off we used to have a
bird feeder sorry I was open my [ __ ]
uh I was opening my [ __ ] thermos
there we just have a bird feeder this
[ __ ] thing would crawl down I need
all the birdseed and I have to wake up
my pajamas sticking my head against the
screen you just want to make noise that
my wife would wake up what are you doing
I'm yelling that [ __ ] squirrel it's
out there stealing all the birdseed and
then she would just start laughing
that's why I married her any woman that
can laugh at me screaming duplicative is
that a goddamn squirrel it [ __ ] 7:00
in the morning is the woman for me I
don't know anything about le squirrels I
know I do know that squirrels in London
were read that I had an affinity for him
all right I'll tell you it was the
craziest thing I was in Hyde Park and I
met me and another red squirrel our eyes
met you know and we kind of had a mole
and it was like this really is the
motherland I'm thinking about joining
our me a few days to decide Jesus Christ
all right
they built been trying to decide if I
should join the army or join the Army
Reserves I'm 26 and just had to move
back into lower level of the duplex
where my father lives upstairs cheaper
rent
I was driving uber after I got laid off
and still doing that while now searching
for direction I have a dream of doing
comedy but I can't afford rent and I
need health insurance as well so
obviously I need a job that will suffice
suffice for rent and bills and hopefully
have health coverage well how do you
start your stand-up career if you join
the army and just to give you a heads up
on the Armed Services as far as the
veterans that I've talked to you want to
join the Navy or the Air Force they have
the best living quarters and if you join
the army or the Marines they treat you
like a [ __ ] animal okay that's what
they told me okay anyways I have
practically no college but I do have
massage therapy certificate and
experience the Army has structured has
structure and Bennie's and jobs but I
feel stupid going in the army because I
don't believe it's for the country yet
those are the values they uphold well
then I yet well if you believe that the
army is fighting for corporations I
would not join the army anyways I have a
few days to decide don't do it before an
aptitude test don't do it but I want to
decide before I unpack or move all my
[ __ ] to the garage and ship out to some
other state or country for full-time
work with the army don't do it also
having trouble picking out a job out of
the math their massive list I'm too old
to be stupid anymore and I don't want to
set myself up so I'm not a deadbeat or a
basket case in the future I wouldn't do
it do you want to be a comedian okay I
would [ __ ] drive for uber I would do
whatever I want I would make that dream
happen okay and do what we all do go eat
some [ __ ] ramen noodles and you know
dress like Malcolm young jeans and a
[ __ ] plain t-shirt and you do that
until you [ __ ] make money all right
but if you're not buying what our
foreign policy is the last thing you
want to do is [ __ ] join up
because that's not gonna be good for
them and it's not gonna be good for you
all right that's easy do not join repeat
you're not gonna join right I don't hear
you all right
not relationship advice oh it's time for
no advice with your host Billy Burr and
I'm ripping off this melody from
somebody else dear Billy the Polar Bear
believer okay this is gonna be a short
one but I messed up big time I emailed
my teacher on Friday I accidentally
ended with the email with love instead
of sincerely my teacher is also a
feminist who everybody is scared of it's
a three-day weekend and I have that
class on Tuesday and I don't know if I
should send another email about that or
talk to her in person I just don't want
another Saturday school thank you and go
[ __ ] yourself what do you mean Saturday
school that gives a [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] she's just your [ __ ] teacher you
know what I would do you know what let
her sit in the awkwardness why do you
have to deal with it you sent love
he won't sincerely your fan yeah who
gives a [ __ ] if she says why did you say
love it's like just be like it's just
something wrong with loving a feminist
and didn't just look at her like she's
out of her mind yeah this is why when
you [ __ ] up in life I've learned this as
a comedian when you [ __ ] up you never
you you blame the crowd that's what you
need to be doing you need to be blaming
the crowd all right people I know this
is only 52 I usually give you an hour
here but my daughter's class is over and
I got to go pick up my lovely wife my
beautiful daughter and take them out to
lunch because it is a holiday out here I
am working on a holiday and as the
parent you
oh it's just so difficult sometimes to
do sixty minutes of a podcast by
yourself okay I'm sorry I came up six
minutes and 52 seconds short all right
that's it I'm gonna try to go upload
this thing at the [ __ ] dance hall
here all right god bless you go [ __ ]
yourselves taking an XFL game have a
good time it's a [ __ ] great time
great people are showing up it's a fun
game who doesn't like football all year
round and guess what if you're not into
that racing is starting up Formula One
MotoGP get into it it's the [ __ ] all
right that's all I have is bread and
circus for you I have no solution
starting up the car here we go all this
is illegal I don't have my [ __ ]
seatbelt on
it's a kid music claptrap eyelash on
glue I don't know what that means go
[ __ ] yourself on francais
[Music]